[Música]
hay dos días dos momentos especialmente
importantes en tu vida el día que naces
y el día que descubres para que naciste
todos tenemos un sueño compartido
un deseo un anhelo profundo en el
corazón ser felices sentirnos plenos
satisfechos orgullosos y seguros de
quiénes somos sin embargo pareciera que
eso es algo muy difícil de alcanzar ya
sea por las circunstancias o porque
nosotros mismos nos podemos poner el pie
quieres saber cómo lograrlo
conciencia congruencia y constancia en
ese orden para alcanzar el sueño más
grande de todos tu propósito de la mejor
versión de ti mismo y cambiar al mundo
cuando tenía 15 años me fui por primera
vez a unas misiones de semana santa en
este momento se sentía la persona más
buena del mundo no basta con cargar un
garrafón de agua sino que estaba 2
cargar cajas de despensa mochila sentir
el sudor en la cara el polvo en la
frente el sol para pensar que estaba
haciendo un verdadero cambio por nuestro
país
más o menos la dinámica de las misiones
siempre es la misma mi equipo y yo
visitamos las casas de varias personas
quienes amablemente abrían la puerta de
sus hogares y nos cuentan de sus
problemáticas de sus preocupaciones de
su día a día normalmente después de
estas pláticas nosotros damos palabras
de aliento de esperanza y en algunas
ocasiones les damos alguna despensa una
lata de atún que frijol un kilo de arroz
en estos encuentros conocí realidades
muy diferentes a las mías
conocí lo que era el hambre lo que era
solamente comer agua con chile
consigue el dolor de perder una hija un
hijo por la violencia por la inmigración
por el abandono
por el narcotráfico trabajos forzados
conocí a crist el niño más inteligente
más movido más alegre que he conocido en
toda mi vida
y que tristemente
no tenía acceso a las mismas
oportunidades educativas un día me puse
a reflexionar en la trascendencia que
estaban teniendo mis acciones
porque yo iba a regresar a la ciudad
a mi burbuja de privilegios de
comodidades pero estas personas
continúan viviendo en la pobreza en esas
problemáticas
verdaderamente con un kilo de frijol y a
cambiar su situación económica y social
el primer paso de este camino es la
conciencia la conciencia es el
conocimiento profundo y reflexivo de uno
mismo y del entorno
ahora toda persona que haya hecho
consciente su exterior y sea consciente
uno mismo se habrá dado cuenta que hay
una constante en la vida y esta es la
crisis
la crisis es una parte intrínseca de la
vida es una parte esencial de la
existencia ahora bien hay dos tipos de
crisis hay crisis individuales y hay
crisis sociales y hay dos formas de
enfrentar la ahora analicemos una
cuando tenía seis años me encantaba
escuchar música con mi papá a eso era
una y media de la tarde salí a la
escuela corría el carro abría la puerta
prendí el radio y disfrutamos juntos
nuestras canciones favoritas de los
virus
después de eso había una pausa
informativa
y algún bloque de noticias
diez personas perdieron la vida
por el narcotráfico hoy en méxico
esa fue una las primeras noticias que
escuche en mi vida con el tiempo me di
cuenta que algo bastante común y por lo
tanto lo normal y se salía de la escuela
iba al carro abría la puerta prendía el
radio y escuchaba y contaba el número de
personas víctimas de la violencia en el
país dos millones setecientos mil
personas han perdido la vida
lamentablemente por kobe 19 un grado
aumentado la temperatura de la tierra en
los últimos 10 años el 42 por ciento de
la población méxico vive en pobreza
lo más grave no son estas estadísticas
los más graves que seguramente tú ya
conocidas todas ellas y seguramente
conoces muchos otros números de muchas
otras problemáticas ya menos que hayas
tenido una experiencia cercana con
alguna de ellas es muy probable que no
estemos haciendo nada al respecto
la crisis más grande que enfrentamos en
la crisis de la indiferencia
cuando una persona pasa a ser sólo un
número entre una estadística y pierde
todo su valor
ahora quiero decirte que esto no es del
todo tu culpa vivimos en un mundo en fox
y cado la infoxicación es un fenómeno de
exceso de información piensa cuenta el
número de veces que ha suprimido la
pantalla de tu teléfono el día de hoy en
alguna red social
solamente sean decenas centenas o hasta
miles de veces
a esto hay que añadirle que por ejemplo
una historia de instagram dura tan solo
15 segundos y siquiera la vemos completa
de hecho si en este momento todavía
tengo tu atención probablemente es un
verdadero milagro qué fácil es pasar a
cien de historia es subir la ventanilla
del carro es voltear la cabeza para no
ver los problemas
hay una frase que me gusta mucho que
dice que el mundo no es un lugar
peligroso
por el mal que se hace
sino por las personas que vemos el mal y
no hacemos nada al respecto
ahora la segunda manera de enfrentar la
crisis es haciéndole cara frente a
frente esto es muchísimo más difícil de
lo que suena porque porque hay que
recordar que nosotros mismos tenemos
nuestras propias crisis existenciales
pensemos
cada vez hay más personas que vienen de
presión más personas ansiosas
frustradas insatisfechas con rabia
hartas de la situación desesperadas
yo no sé qué hacer con mi vida y tú
quieres que ayude a alguien más la
crisis de los 40 años no es otra cosa
que una persona que entra primaria
secundaria preparatoria universidad
entro al trabajo seguramente
probablemente era algo que ni siquiera
le gustaba pero tenía que ganarse la
vida tenía que tener algún ingreso
identi de la nada un día se despierta y
se da cuenta que nada de lo que ha hecho
le gusta y eso no es una cuestión de
edad también hay jóvenes que no saben
qué hacer con su vida no sabemos a dónde
ir
el mundo se cae a pedazos y yo también
qué puede hacer al respecto
la solución es el propósito
el propósito tiene cuatro
características
es algo que además es algo para lo que
eres bueno es algo que el mundo necesita
y es algo que te genera valor personal
pero por sobre todas las cosas el
propósito de todo ser humano
consiste en amar
y sentirnos amados
una vez que regresamos de aquellas
misiones me senté con mis amigos a la
mesa y les pregunté qué es lo que más te
molesta del mundo
a mí lo que más me molesta dijo uno
es que no se les pague adecuadamente a
los científicos y a los artesanos
adm y lo que más me molesta dijo otro
son las posiciones precarias en las que
viven los campesinos
a mí lo que más me molesta es la
contaminación
y seguramente en la última semana te has
quejado por lo menos has pensado en
alguna queja de alguna problemática
social económica política o ecológica
y entonces viene la siguiente pregunta y
hoy que estamos siendo al respecto para
cambiar esa realidad
ahí es donde todo cambia porque todo el
mundo nos quejamos pero pocas personas
decidimos tomar acción
esto es el siguiente paso la congruencia
que tus pensamientos tus palabras y sus
acciones esté en el mismo camino
pero con esto no me refiero solamente a
ir a unas misiones
sería un error creernos el salvador
decirse es que voy a resolver toda esta
problemática porque dedique una semana a
resolver un problema dos semanas diez
semanas asistir a una marcha
la congruencia requiere dar la vida por
un ideal por un objetivo
fue así como decidí con mis amigos
comenzar a combatir la indiferencia
mediante la recolección de botellas de
plástico para ser conciencia ambiental
el reciclaje
durante un mes nos dedicamos mis amigos
y yo a juntar todas las botellas que
podíamos y después de un duro mes las
fuimos a entregar a un centro de acopio
y me siento muy orgulloso de decir que
juntamos la gran cantidad
de 2 kilos
ahora que recibimos la cuantiosa
cantidad de ocho pesos más o menos 40
centavos de dólar
en este momento quiero que sepas que el
fracaso es parte del camino los errores
las equivocaciones
pero justamente a partir de ahí es donde
podemos crecer más
ponte a pensar
en una vasija
preciosa de porcelana blanca muy bien
decorada maya que un día vas caminando y
era nada
se cae por equivocación se parte en mil
pedazos
y ahí está
estás viendo la vasija rota qué vas a
hacer con ella
la vas a tirar
probablemente lo primero que pienses
en japón hay una técnica de reparación
que a mí me encanta que consiste en
tomar cada uno de los pedazos rotos y
pegarlos con oro así la vasija se vuelve
más única y más valiosa justamente a
partir
de sus roturas
esta es la belleza de las heridas la
belleza de los errores
es normal aprender es normal equivocarse
debes comprender debes saber que te vas
a equivocar lo importante es que
tengamos un objetivo claro un ideal el
propósito hacerlo consciente trabajar
por él y en el camino adquirir
experiencia y justamente esta
experiencia esté mancharte las manos es
lo que me lleva al tercer punto
constancia o vídeo un poeta romano decía
que una gota no hace hoyo en una piedra
por la fuerza
sino por el número de veces que cae en
ella
las cosas buenas
toman tiempo
pero vale la pena
sabes qué pasó después con esto de las
botellas
mira a iván mike el loco de las botellas
miraba el niño pepenador recogiendo otra
botella más
las burlas valieron la pena
cada vez que tuve que ir a un basurero
valió la pena
cada botella aplastada con mi equipo
vale valió y valdrá la pena porque yo sé
que con que toquemos una sola vida es
más que suficiente al día de hoy hemos
juntado más de 6000 kilos y con lo
recuperado promovemos diferentes
acciones sociales y mi sueño más grande
en el mundo es que algún día podemos
pagar solventar la educación para niños
como cris
mi propósito es combatir la indiferencia
es hacer conciencia de estos problemas y
cambiar el mundo a partir las cuestiones
ambientales
cuál es tu propósito
congruencia
conciencia y constancia
congruencia sabes cuál es tu mayor sueño
cuál es tu miedo más profundo
cuál es tu fortaleza
y cuál es tu mayor debilidad
sabes cuál es tu propósito
te has hecho una pausa en tu vida
para pensarlo para meditarlo
ponte en silencio y descubre primero
cuál es tu objetivo
siguiente
congruencia actúas
haces hoy algo para alcanzar aquello que
has hecho consciente
trabajas por un mundo mejor
y constancia lo haces todos los días
trabajas día a día por ello
ahora creo que esto es más como un
círculo porque si de algo te puedo
asegurar es que vivirás si no es que ya
viviste o vives una crisis porque la
porque la crisis es parte de nuestra
existencia de la crisis creces recuerda
eso recuerda que hay un propósito que
solamente tú puedes cumplir
recuerda que eres una persona única
llamada
y en ese momento has conciencia
recuérdalo
toma acción congruencia
y determina a trabajar todos los días
incansablemente por ello en constancia
sueña aspira a cosas grandes
se el cambio que quieres ver en el mundo
cuál es tu propósito
conciencia congruencia y constancia es
el camino para lograr el sueño más
grande de todos tu propósito ser la
mejor versión en ti mismo y cambiar al
mundo
[Música]